[موسيقى]
نرحب بكل المشاهدين وترحيب خاص بضيوف هذه
الحلقه ضيوف تشاهدونهم على الشاشه ويمكنكم
هتتفاعل مع مايقولون على صفحه البرنامج
على فيسبوك او على صفحه البرنامج على
تويتر
عن مباراه الليله في المونديال بين
المنتخب
الفريقان مره واحده عام 89 في فرنسا في
مباراه فاز فيها الايرانيون مباراه تتزامن
مع حركه احتجاجيه كبيره لما فاز الفريق
الايرانيه على لما فا- فاز الفريق
الايراني على ويل تم الافراج عن معتقلين
700 معتقل وحتى المرشد الاعلى نشر تغريده
رحب فيها بالفوز وعندما يقول وزير
الخارجيه الامريكيه وتولينكن ان الامر يظل
مجرد مباراه كره قدم هل هذا يعني ان دائره
السياسه ليست على المستطيل فالدوحه نناقش
الموضوع ومعي من بيروت نجاه شرف الدين
وزميلها صحفيه وكاتبه سياسيه سعيد بان
يكون معنا من القاهره بشير عبد الفتاح
باحث في شان الايراني في مركز الاهرام
للدراسات السياسيه والاستراتيجيه وسعيد
بان يكون معنا من كامبردج مكرم خوري وهو
استاذ العلاقات الدوليه والاعلام السياسي
اهلا وسهلا بكم قبل ان نبدا نستمع لما
يقوله مشجع للمنتخب الامريكي
نحن قلقون بشان ذلك منذ ان وصلنا الى هنا
اليس كذلك لقد جئنا الى هنا لمشاهده كره
القدم لسنه لم اجل المواقف السياسيه نريد
تعمل الولايات المتحده ودعم حقوق المراه
في ايران بالطبع نحن ندعموها صحيح نحن
لسنا هنا لاتخاذ موقف سياسي في الوقت
الحالي نريد مشاهده كره القدم والاستمتاع
بوقتنا واتمنى الافضل للفريقين
وماذا قال مشجع اخر
من الواضح
ايران ليست مضطره للفوز يمكنهم بشكل
اساسيا لاحتفاظ بخط الدفاع عالم تماما كما
فعل الفريق السعودي ضد الارجنتين محاوله
تطبيق مصيده التسلل والتراجع وانتظار وصول
الكره اليهم لذلك اذا ارادوا فعل ذلك من
الناحيه التكتيكيه فيمكنهم جعلوا الامر
صعب جدا بالنسبه لنا
وماذا قال اللاعب السابق في المنتخب
الايراني قاسم بور
التقينا بالمنتخب الامريكي مرتين وفزنا في
المواجهتين الفرصه تبدو ساني حالنا لتحقيق
الانجاز شرط ان لا المصاب بالغرور المنتخب
الامريكي الذي نواجهه الان يتم اعداده
للمونديال المقبل في امريكا ولديه نجوم
بارزون ومحترفون في الدوريات الاوروبيه
او الساحه الاساسيه للتعبير عن الاشتباك
الاساسي بين امريكا وايران
من خلال الاستعدادات اليوم انت تعلم ان
السفاره الايرانيه تتحدث اليوم وهناك مركز
مخصص دعا فيه السفير الايراني لحضور هذه
المباريات وكذلك سفاره الامريكيه وبالتالي
طبعا بيروت هي ساحه ربما تكون الوحيده في
المنطقه اليوم طيب ولكن هذه المباراه
كل هذه الاشياء
ولكن هي مباراه يتحدث عنها كثيرون هناك
تركيز على الطابع السياسي والعلاقات
الامريكيه الايرانيه اكثر من حديث عن لعبه
كره قدم حتى انا قدام اللاعبين
هناك مؤشرات عديده هي واكبت هذه المباراه
يعني في المونديال طبعا نحن راينا موضوع
العلم والتي تحول كما هو معروف الى ماده
للسجال السياسي ما بين ايران والولايات
المتحده الامريكيه فبالتالي بدات مع هذه
المؤشرات التي تدل على ان التوتر السياسي
بدا ينعكس ومن ثم الاعلام الذي تحدث ايضا
عن الضغوط على اللاعبين الاراديين
وبالتالي هذا مؤشر على ان السياسه ايضا
تدخل في ذلك والدعوه الى مناصره همم
المتظاهرين والاحتجاجات التي تحصل في
ايران فكل هذه المؤشرات والعوامل ساعدت
على ان يعني لا تكون هذه المباريات مجرد
مباريات بين فريقين يتنافسان على الفوز
وانه ايران ستتاهل او الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه ستتاهل وانما هي مباراه بخلفيه
سياسيه وهي من دوله تفرض عقبات على الدوله
الاخرى المفروض عليها عقوبات وفريقها
يلعبان على نفس الملعب
مختلفه في القاهره اكيد الجميع سيتاب هذه
المباراه ولكن لا ينحاز للطرف ولا لاخر
ولكن هذه المباراه يعني الكل يتحدث عنها
منذ ان حصلت عمليه القرعه
تحيه لك توفيق وضيفك الكريمين ولكل مشاهدي
هذا النقاش في كل مكان القاهره اا دائما
تواقه الى السباقات الرياضيه لاسيهما كره
القدم ومونديال كاس العالم هذه المره في
قطر لذلك هناك همم يعني همم متابعه دقيقه
من جانب المصريين خصوصا لهذه المباراه
التي تكتسب خصوصيه شديده كون السياسه قد
القت بظلالها على المونديال ولم يكن
مونديال قطر وحده هو الذي سقط في مباراه
السياسه وانما اا الرياضه لم تسلم منذ
بدايتها من السياسه ان جميع ان نتذكر هنري
كيسنجر في دبلوماسيه البين بونج 1972
لانهاء الجفاء واذابه الجليد بين امريكا
والصين نتذكر الحرب التي دارت ما بين
هندوراس والسيلفادور عام 1969 من قبل
مونديال المكسيك 1970 حينما ال سلفادور
بثلاثه ثلاثيه نظيفه وتاهلت على حسابه
هندوراس تصاعدت خلافات حدوديه بسبب هذه
المباراه وادت الى معركه ال 100 ساعه همم
وحرب ال 100 ساعه ما بين الدولتين نتذكر
في العام 1978 حينما طلب جامبول سارتر
وغيره من الفلاسفه في فرنسا بمقاطعه
مونديال كاس العالم في الارجنتين
1978 بسبب سياسات همم الرئيس خورخي في
ديله همم المناهضه لحقوق الانسان نتذكر
ايضا كيف كانت الرياضه وسيله لتقريب ما
بين الشعوب او الصدام ما بين الشعوب لذلك
علم الاجتماع الرياضي اا يركز ويسلط الضوء
على العلاقه الوثيقه ما بين الرياضه عموما
وسياسه وما بين كره القدم والسياسه القوه
الكبرى تميل دائما الى تاسيس الرياضه وكره
القدم ومن المفارقات توفيق ان اعتدى دول
العالم والقوى العظمى مثل الولايات
المتحده وروسيا الصين وكندا اا تجد اداؤها
الرياضي ضعيفا وخافتا للغايه روسيا لم تصل
الى تصفيات كاس العالم امريكا وكندا وديان
اداء سيئا الصين هي الاخرى طيب تجد
المفارقات يعني
بكره ماكره مكرم خوري في مبالغه في
التسييس برايك لهذه المباراه يعني بناء
على ما تفضلت به الاستاذه من بيروت
واقترحت ان لبنان هي المركز اعتقد انه
وفقا للرسائل التي وصلتني كانت كالتالي
لاول مره امريكا وايران يلتقيان ولكن خارج
العراق وخارج اليمن وخارج فلسطين خارج
سوريا وخارج لبنان اذا همم بالتاكيد فان
هذه المباراه وعليها العلاقات الدوليه
والاجواء السياسيه ولكن لماذا يا استاذ
توفيق هنا نحن في ما يسمى بع السيميائيات
نحن نبدا من الرموز لدينا فريقين فريق
واحد يلبس او يرتدي العلم الايراني الى
جانب العلم الامريكي وليست هناك علاقات
دبلوماسيه لبل كان هناك انهيار منذ 42
عاما لهذه العلاقات هذا واحد ثانيا هناك
النشيد الوطني ونذكر كيف ان البعض ادعى ان
اللاعبين الايرانيين لم ينشدوا النشيد
الوطني مع انه اذا ما قارنت بقيه الفرق
والمجموعات من دول اخرى اغلبها لم تنشد
اصلا النشيد الوطني ولكن بالتاكيد ان هذا
اللقاء اليوم هو عباره عن حوار غير سياسي
برموزن سياسيه جليه المعالم الان النقطه
الثالثه شمال
هناك ما يسمى بديبلوماسيه الرياضه واعتقد
انه رغم ان هذه مباراه وطبعا بالتاكيد
ايران تريد ان تربح او على الاقل تخطي ان
تربح اعتقد انه حوار بشكل غير مباشر يعني
هو شبيه ولكن ليس 98
فرنسا
ولكن ليس هذا الموضوع الان همم خلافا طبعا
لعلاقات قطر مع بقيه الدول ولكن بالتاكيد
هناك علاقات دبلهماسيه تجري اليوم عبر هذه
اللعبه الرياضيه الان من هو الجانب الذي
يهتم اكثر بنتائج هذه المباراه بالتاكيد
هو الجانب الايراني لماذا لانه محاصر
ولانه في الشرق ولانه هو الطرف الذي اخذ
يتحمل كل العقوبات من
بيلانت هذه العقود وبالتالي فهو بالنسبه
له احراز هدفا ايه في كره القدم في مرمى
الفريق الامريكي هو بالاحرى احراز هدف في
اطار مرمى المعنويات القوميه وهذا ما يهمه
ان ذلك نجاه شرف الدين هناك توظيف هذه
المباراه حتى داخليا في ايران
اليوم بحاجه لهذا الربح ليس فقط لتاهل
للدوري 16 وبالتالي هي بحاجه لان تربح على
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ولكن ايضا هي
بحاجه للمعنويات خاصه بظل الاحتجاجات التي
تحصل داخل ايران وما كنا قد اشرنا اليه من
موضوع النشيد الوطني
كذلك بالنسبه لموضوع العالم وغيرهم من
الرسائل التي
عند العالم طلبت بطرد
المنتخب الامريكي يعني بموضوع العالم طبعا
طلبت من الفيفا
مؤشر الى الضيف من ضيف من كامبردج يشكك في
مساله في مساله في مساله النشيد الوطني هو
يقول لاعب مش صحيح بس بكل ما قلناه وكل ما
رايناه وكل ما سمعناه هو ان الفريق امتنع
طبعا انا النشيد الوطني
قولي يا استاذ توفيق ان الفريق امتنع هاتف
في المباراه مع فريق الانجليزي امتنعى
ولكنه عاد وهمم المباراه مع ويلز ثم انشد
النشيد الوطني
النشيد مدرب الفريق اعلن تاييده للتظاهرات
وادانه اسلوب السلطات في التعاطي مع هذه
التظاهرات كما ان لاعبي المنتخب الايراني
بعدما اتهمهم ايرانيون بالتواطئ مع النظام
ضد الشعب ارادوا ان يعزلوا انفسهم عن
النظام وبالتالي اعلنوا التاييد والانحياز
للجماهير وليه التظاهرات وربما هذا ما دفع
بالحرس الثوري همم الموجود في قطر والذي
يقوم بعمليه مراقبه للمنتخب بالتهديد
بالفعل هددهم في ذويهم وعائلاتهم وهددهم
بالتنكيل بهم حاله تعودتهم الى البلاد اذا
ما اظهروا اشارات مناهضه للنظام بغض النظر
عن همم مساله السلام الوطني او النشيد
الوطني
ذلك بشكل مباشر يعني المنتخب الايراني لم
يتحدث بشكل مباشره عن تاييد للاحتجاجات
وبالتالي لا يمكن تبني هذه النظريه
بانتظار يعني ما سيقوم به المنتخب
الايراني طبعا هناك مؤشرات تدل بموضوع
النشيد الوطني ولكن ليس اكثر ولا اقل يعني
لا ناخذ الامور اكثر من حجمها
سماعات نشاطات مخابراتيه على الفريق
الايراني بشكل خاص يعني مثلا نحن في
بريطانيا
يا سيدي ليس لدي مصادر استخباراتيه وانما
وسائل الاعلام انا طلعت هذه الاخبار عبر
وسائل الاعلام دوليه محيده اشارت الى هذا
الامر والى دور الحرس الثوري ومتابعته
يعني يا استاذ عبد الفتاح دون الدخول الان
الى الدول يعني لو كان الفريق مصري هو قام
شخص معين همم لادعاء ان هناك مئات لسجناء
المصريين الذين ماتوا في سجون مصر يعني هل
كنت ستصدق او ستعارض اي حال هذه المساله
مستغله مستغله سياسيا من قبل الاطراف
تعارض ايران كل من له شان في شان سياسي
لمعارضه ايران الان بسبب الانتقام
في الاحتجاجات درف القمر حتى السلطات
الايرانيه اعترفت بمقتل 300 شخص في هذه
الاحتجاجات منذ قليل اذا اردت
ههه
ليش تطلع مع عبد الفتاح انا اسالك
الحقيقه امامي على الوكلات السلطات
الايرانيه اعترفت بمقتل 300 الحقيقه امامي
مكتوبه بالصحف العبريه الاسرائيليه عندما
تقراها تفهم ان غالبيه انا لا اقول انه
ليس هناك مظاهرات في ايران طبعا هناك
مظاهره ولكن ما اقوله او غالبيه ما يجري
في ايران هي عباره عن مخططات مدروسه محضره
بالدرج مسبقا كما تم تحضير المباراه
لا لا لا ليس هناك مؤامرات انك هذا الكلام
هذا الكلام فيه تقليل يا سيدي الفاضل هذا
الكلام فيه تقليل لا هذا الكلام فيه تقليل
من شان العمل الذي يقوم به الشعب الايراني
ثوره ايران لم تكتمل في العام 1979 وهناك
موجات ثوريه لتصحيح المسار
المعارض المصري من السجن
بمناسبه توفيق الاخ علاء عبد الفتاح ساجين
جنائي وليس سجينا سياسيا ويقضي مده عقوبه
مقابل جريمه جنائيه وتحدثنا عنه مطولا في
في في قمه المناخ طبعا نعم
لا تمثل ايران بس الدفع شويه
الصحافه الفرنسيه هي التي اتت الخبر نقلا
عن مسؤول ايراني
يا استاذي انا لا بجد بجد اصحاب في
الفرنسيه لان وكاله الصحافه الفرنسيه كانت
اولى الوكلات التي جندت للحرب ضد سوريا
على سبيل المثال لكن دعك الان من الحياد
لانه تقريبا لا يوجد حياد في وسائل
الاعلام كل وسيله الاعلام
تتحدث بنفس الطريقه يعني
وايضا
او
السابق تابع لرويترز ولكن ليس هذا الموضوع
الموضوع هو فقط يعني نلخص الموضوع هو ان
ايران مستهدفه وهذا شيء واضح وان اداره
هذه العمليه تاتي من تل ابيب هذا واضح
وبالتاكيد انه اي هجوم امريكي سياسي
اعلامي ضد ايران هو ايضا مخطط له اقليميا
ليس فقط من امريكا ولكن ايضا من وكلاء
امريكا في الاقليم ولذلك تظن ايران ويظن
الايرانيون الان اولئك الذين في لبنان او
داعمهم في كل مكان في العالم ان انتصار في
لعبه كره القدم اليوم سيرفع من معنوياتهم
وسيعدوا هدفا في مرمى الشباك الامريكي
الذي لا طالما
نترك تتفاعل معك تفضلي
ربما هي هذه الفكره الاساسيه التي اوافق
يعني مع دكتور مكرم ح وهو الموضوع ال
لبنان وكيفيه التعاطي مع هذه المباراه في
لبنان وقد كنت قد اشرت اليه ولكن ان يكون
هناك استعدادات في بعض المناطق التي يسيطر
عليها حزب الله
وشاشات وحضور جماهيري لمشاهده هذه
المباريات والاعلام اللبناني كيف يتعاطى
ايضا مع هذه المساله ان كان عبر التغطيات
الصحفيه والشاشات التي تخصص مراسلين في
معظم المناطق لمتابعه هذه المباريات
ولبحث في خلفيه ما اذا كانت ايران ستربح
وانعكاس ذلك على الجمهور اللبناني يعني
طبعا هنا يجب التوقف عنده ويجب التوقف على
مدى انه الساحه اللبنانيه ان تكون هذه
الابعاد همم وحاضره في هذه الساحه
اللبنانيه الى هذه الدرجه خاصه ان هناك
انقسام كبير في داخل اللبناني في هناك
جمهور مؤيد للجانب الايراني وهناك جمهور
مؤيد للجانب الامريكي وستكون هناك
اناس يشاهدون الفريقين وهم مع الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه وفي اعلام امريكيه ايضا
ستكون حاضره وبالتالي في انقسام كبير في
الساحه اللبنانيه يعبر عنه بشكل واضح هذا
الاشتباك السياسي الايراني الامريكي
ونعود الى المباراه يعني طبعا هي معنويات
اساسيه بالنسبه لايران ومعنويه اساسيه
ايضا للجانب الامريكي طبعا نعرف انه
المحادثات على خلفيه الاتفاق النووي
الايراني هي متوقفه الان ولكن المعنويه
المعنويه اذا ما ربحت ايران سيكون لها
انعكاس معنوي لن تؤثر على هذا الاتفاق لن
تؤثر الى عوده المفاوضات ولا الى يعني
توقفها وبالتالي نجاح فريق ايران او نجاح
فريق الولايات المتحده لن يكن له اي تاثير
سياسي بشكل مباشر على المسار السياسي
القائم بين الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
وايران
صحيح عندما يقول
الامر يتعلق
بمجرد مباراه كره قدم محاولا ان يخفف طبعا
من وضعت هذا الثقل لان هناك ثقل كبير ان
كانت كل الصحف تتحدث عن هذا الموضوع
وتعطيه طابعا سياسيه لا يمكن ان نتغذى عنه
ولا نتحدث عنه
الى حد ان كبير لان مساله تسييس المباريات
بغرض تخدير الشعوب فكره ان الرياضه تقدير
افيون الشعوب او كره القدم افيون للشعوب
هذا بشكل كبير في الدول العربيه او الدول
العالم الثالث التي تريد ان تحول
الانتصارات الرياضيه او الثقافيه على سبيل
المثال الى انجازات ضخمه تقارع بها كبريات
الدول او تعوض بها اخفاقات عسكريه او
سياسيه او اقتصاديه هذا موجود الى حد كبير
في ثقافات الدول العالم الثالثيه همم قد
توجد استثناءات في دول العالم الاول لكنها
محدوده لكن يختلف مع بنت ايضا لان الرياضه
مرتبطه بسياسه شئنا امام والولايات
المتحده كانت سباقه وقد اشارته الى نموذج
كيسنجر في مساله دبلوماسيه البنت مع الصين
في العام 1972 ايضا ما جرى خلال الايام
الفائته يعني المنتخب الامريكي على سبيل
المثال حينما يعرض عالم ايران ايام
في دعم واضح للمتغيرين الاداره الامريكيه
عبرت غير مره عن دعمها للتظاهرات
والاحتجاجات في ايران رغم اعلانيها انها
لا تريد اسقاط النظام الايراني وانا على
يقين من ان الولايات المتحده لا تسعى الى
اسقاط النظام الايراني ولا حتى اسرائيل
بالمناسبه لان وجود هذا النظام يخدم
المصالح الامريكيه والاسرائيليه بالاساس
ولا تريد الولايات المتحده ان تفقد مغانم
بقاء هذا النظام لكنها ومراعاتا لمشاعر
المتظاهرين الايرانيين وتناغوما مع فكره
الدعم الديمقراطيه وحقوق الانسان وحق
التظاهر السلمي في كل مكان هي تظهر دائما
واضحا للمتظاهرين ولكن من دون ان تفضي
تظاهرات الى اسقاط النظام الايراني لذلك
الاختلاف جزئي وكلي مع عنتر بنكن في هذا
السياق ايضا فيما يتعلق بمساله ان ايران
مستهدفه كل الدول المستهدفه والا بماذا
تفسر الادوار التي تقوم بها اجهزه الاستخ
وحروب الجيل الرابع وحروب الجيل الخامس
وتوظيف الذكاء الاصطناعي على سبيل المثال
وتحذير هنري كيسنجر هذا الرجل الذي يبلغ
ال 100 عام الان واخر اصداراته السياسيه
يحذر فيها من مخاطر الذكاء الاصطناعي على
الصراعات الدوليه والعلاقات ما بين الدول
فالجميع مستهدف لكن يجب ان نشير بدون
الحياز او همم تحيز بان ايران بها مشكله
حقيقيه الشعب الايراني بحاجه الى التعبير
عن نفسه الثوره الايرانيه لم تكتمل وهناك
مشاكل حقيقيه لدى النظام السياسي في ايران
ومن ثم الثوره او الانتفاضه التي تشهدها
ايران حاليا هي مبرره بكل المقاييس ان لم
تكون المطلوبيه اقتصاديه اجتماعيه فهي
سياسيه ايضا لذلك هذه المباريات همم تعكس
همم ابعادا سياسيه مهمه للغايه وان كان
الامر بشكل مبالغ فيه لدى الجانب الامريكي
الايراني عفوا لانه كما ذكرنا في العالم
الثالث
تفضل الانتصارات الرياضيه كتعويض عن
اخفاقات عسكريه واقتصاديه طيب فيما يتعلق
بالتوظيف ضيفي من كامبردج حتى المرشد
الاعلى استخدم تويتر ورحب بالانتصار على
منتخب ويلز يعني انخرط طبعا في هذا
التوظيف السياسي لكره القدم بالتاكيد
وهناك ربمانيه لصرف الانذار عما يجري في
الداخل من مظاهرات واحتجاجات
اي رئيس في اي بلد بالعالم
الرئيس هو الرئيس السيسي
نعم نعم ولكن هذا هو الرئيس الروحاني يعني
همم هو اه او غيره بالتاكيد اي في العالم
يجب عليها ان يقوم بتشجيع فريقه ومنتخب به
الوطني هذه مساله عاديه يعني الم ترى محمد
بن سلمان يرقص في صالته عندما فازت
السعوديه لا طيب عادي شيء عادي نحن لا لن
نقول الان محمد بن سلمان يوظف والى
اخره هكذا تسير
الامور
تجري في احتجاجات منذ فتره طويله في ايران
لهذا ترى لا اقارن ولكن اقول لك
انا اريد ان اكون الترا همم يعني اوبجكتف
معكم هيا
هيا هل هل لاي احد اجابه لماذا لا تقوم
قنواتك قطر كلها الاعلاميه بتغطيه
المظاهرات في ايران اذا اجبتني على ذلك
انت تفهم بكل العلاقات الدوليه في العالم
لماذا لان هناك اتفاقيات ما بين سياسه
والاعلام والرياضه والى اخره يعني ما اريد
ما عندنا اتفاقيات مع اي احد نتحدث عن كل
المواضيع ههه
ده ممتاز حاليا لم انفصل الامر ههه
يا عاديه الملوك عندنا عندنا في بريطانيا
دائما ترى غالبيه العائله المالكه في
ملاعب التنس يعني خذ في ملاعب التنس في
هامبلدون ويليام وكيد دائما هناك خذ في
لعبه اخرى مباريات اخرى كلهم
بريطانيا لا يوجد شيء اسمه تسليه السياسه
مرتبطه بالاقتصاد وبالرياضه وبالرياضه
مدخول الرياضه هي بزنس كما هي رياضه وكما
هي الشعور وطني كلهم مرتبط ببعضهم وانا
اتفق مع الاستاذه نجاه من بيروت عندما
قالت
احد من من ايران رسمي لمشاهده هذه
المباريات مباشره في الدوري الذي تتعلق
بالامنيات انا هكذا اعتقد
في قطر في قطر يعني هلا قطر حصلت فيها
يعني تقريبا تقريبا
لا يمكنك ان تدخل قطر هكذا
من المشاهدين
رائعه
وفي شاشات عملاقه في الضاحيه الجنوبيه وفي
مناطق عديده من لبنان يتم حضور هذه
المباراه وهو بدعوه من السفيره الايراني
لا اعرف ولكن حسب رايك
الاوضاع السياسيه الغير مستقره في ايران
والانقسام العمودي داخل النخبه الحاكمه في
ايران ايران منذ تم اغتصاب الثوره في عام
1981 وباتت اسلاميه صرف رغم انها لم تكن
كذلك في البدايه كانت ليبراليه يا ساريه
اسلاميه لكن الاسلاميين اختطفوها منذ ذلك
التوقيت وهناك صراع دافين ما بين اجنحه اا
مغتصبي الثوره من العسكريين ومن
الاسلاميين او من اصحاب العمامات لذلك
الان هناك صراع في ايران قد يفضي الى تحول
ايران من همم نظام في قراتي ديكتاتوريه
دينيه الى ديكتاتوريه عسكريه تقول الامور
الى حرس الثوري على سبيل المثال وهناك
صراع تحت الرماد صراع مبطن ما بين رجال
الدين وما بين الحرس الثوري اعتقد انه
سيفضي الى تحول نحو دكتاتوريه عسكريه الا
اا تعاود ايران طريق الديمقراطيه مجددا
والحكم المدني ومن ثم يلا تسمح بان يخرج
رئيس ايران اتفضل اتفضل استاذ عبد الفتاح
وكان وكان الاستاذ بشير يقرا نصا كتب من
قبل معارض مصري عن مصر هذه تماما المفردات
التي يستعملونها انت مصر رفي ايران بمصر
لماذا تربط ايران بمصر دائما يعني لماذا
تاخذنا الى مصر نحن نتحدث عن ايران
اذا اراد توفيق اذا اراد توفيق ان يحول
الحوار الى مصر ليس لدي اي مانع للنقاش في
الموضوع
موضوعي ليس لدي اي انحيازات
يؤثر ايران تحت الحصار هي سياسات النظام
الايراني التي ادت الى هذا الحصار يا سيدي
هذه العقوبات ليست فقط بسبب البرنامج
النووي انتظر الفتره لحظه لحظه من فضلك
هذه العقوبات بسبب رعايه ايران للارهاب
بسبب انتهاك الديمقراطيه وحقوق الانسان
بسبب البرنامج النووي والصاروخي والمسيرات
بسبب التدخل في شؤون دول الجوار بسبب
ارسال المسيرات الى روسيا مؤخرا في الحرب
الاوكرانيا يعني هناك حزمه من الاسباب
لفرض هذه العقوبات وبالمناسبه ليست كلها
عقوبات امريكيه صرفه وانما هناك عقوبات
اوروبيه وهناك عقوبات دوليه نظام الايراني
وسياسات النظام الايراني
هتديمقراطيه وانا موجود في بريطانيا التي
تدعي انها ام البرلمانات وكله صوري وعندما
تاتي الامور الى الامور العنفيه نرى نرى
اشياء مختلفه كليا بود القول ان موضوع
العمامات واتهام هذا الحكم في ايران وانا
على فكره شخصيا لست من انصار ايات حكم
دينه ولكن هذه مساله اخرى لست شخصيا هنا
همم يعني اذا تدخل ولكن ما اقوله هل سمعت
عن مصدق بالتاكيد سمعت عن مصدق وما ارادت
امريكا ان تفعله اردت ان تستحوذ على النفط
الايراني ولم يقبل
مصدق امريكا تريد يا استاذ امريكا تريد ان
تكون كل الدول في العالم العربي او المشرق
العربي محكومه لها ان حكمت لها اهلا بها
تكون ديكتاتوريه تكون شيعيه تكون ما تكون
انظر الى ركوع امريكا الى فنزويلا يوم امس
ارادوا ان يخضع ولا انتهى النفط في امريكا
يريدون نفط بني زويلا يريدون ان يولدوه
معك تماما اتفق معك يا دكتور خوري في ان
امريكا لا تريد نشر الديكورات سياحيه في
العالم امريكا
ليست ليس من مصلحه امريكا ان تكون كل دول
العالم ديمقراطيه
امريكا بدليل
طيب طيب نموذج التركي
الديمقراطيمقراطيه في تركيا تؤرق امريكا
منذ احتلال العراق 2003 ورفض البرلمان
التركي دخول القوات الامريكيه الى العراق
عبر تركيا الولايات المتحده تتعامل مع
الشيطان من اجل مصلحتها وهي تخلت فعليا عن
فكره 12 الديمقراطيه وحقوق الانسان
وتستغلهما فقط كاوراق ضغط وابتزاز على
حكومات ودول العالم كلما اخترت الظروف
اتفق معك في ذلك ولكن على حكام الدول
المختلفه خصوصا دول العالم الثالث ان لا
تتيح الفرصه للولايات المتحده لفرد
العقوبات والحصار والتدخل هذا ما فعله
صدام حسين العراق ويفعله نظام الملالي في
ايران للاسف الشديد طيب نجاه انا لا اريد
نستخدم نظريه المؤامره ولا تحدث عن هذه
المؤامره بس اريد ان اسالك يعني اختار هذا
التوقيت بان لكي يعلن عن النسخه الثانيه
من القمه من اجل الديمقراطيه قبل قليل
فالتاسع والعشرين والثلاثين من شهر مارس
يعني اخ يوم المباراه ويعلن القمه من اجل
الديمقراطيه بالنظر الى ما يجري في ايران
في يعني
ربط بين الاثنين
كله مربط بعده
رساله او رساله ربما رساله لايران على
موضوع الديمقراطيه ولكن هنا يعني يمكن
اتفق معه ضايفك في مساله صحيح
الديمقراطي وحقوق الانسان وغيره يعني هذا
موضوع موضوع حقوق الانسان يعني واذا ما
اشارنا الى انه هناك في ربما حوار بين
امريكا وايران في حال وصول هذا الحوار الى
تسويه ما فان ذلك ينعكس بطبيعه الحال على
مناطقنا وبشكل اساسي المناطق لبنان سوريا
والعراق واليمن وغيرها وبالتالي يعني
موضوع الديمقراطيه لا يصبح هو موضوعا
اساسيا في السياسات ربما اوروبا تهتم اكثر
بهذه المساله موضوع الديمقراطيه في همم
الدول همم الدول همم المتوسط ودول الشرق
انما بالنسبه الاتفاقات السياسيه الكبرى
يعني الولايات المتحده الامريكيه اليوم
ترفض التدخل الايراني المباشر في دول مثل
العراق ولبنان وسوريا واليمن وغيرها يعني
الدور الايراني الذي اصبح اكبر من ايران
في المنطقه هي تحاول تحجيم هذا الدور في
هذه المناطق والحوار حول الاتفاق الايراني
في جانب منه يتعلق بدور ايران الذي توسع
في هذه المناطق على حساب حلفائها في هذه
المناطق وبالتالي في الملفات السياسيه
الكبرى تصبح حقوق الانسان هامشيه على هامش
التسويات الكبرى السياسيه ان كان بين
الاولاد المتحده وايران او غيرها من الدول
التي تعاقد معها اتفاقات كبرى في هذه
المناطق والان نعود الى المباريات يعني
طبعا الساعه 9:00 بكون في مباريات حاميه
ههه
ههه طيب اريد اريد ضيفا اريد ضيفي اريد
ضيف الله ههه من كبر زي التفاعل مع مهم ما
كنت تقولي لنا حول حول ايران انا اعتقدت
وانا نجات يعني كانت في خطك ولكن يبدو ان
النجاشيات لها موقف همم يعني
لا شك انه هناك اوضاع سياسيه معقده وهناك
جبهتين بالاساس في العالم العربي جبهه
التطبيع والتتبيع الصهيو الامريكيه والتي
هي مع ان تبقى فلسطين محتله بشكل كامل
فيها احتلال فاحش يقتل ويقصف ويسجن ويعذب
وهؤلاء المطبعين المتبعين هم في هذه
المجال او هذه السله وهناك الحلف الاخر او
الجبهه الاخرى التي تسمي نفسك جبهه
المقاومه وهذه مساله يعني
ايران علاقات عاديه مع الامارات
يا استاذ الكريم انت هناك من العلاقات
الدوليه هناك فرق ما بين العلاقات
الثنائيه العلاقات الثنائيه بين دولتين
مثلا ما بين ايران وقطر
ايران والامارات وما بين ايران نعم نعم
لان تربطهم مثلا عندما كان الحصار على على
قطر ايران هي كانت التي انقذت بصفه الجوار
طبعا انقذت قطر بشكل او اخر وهي هناك
تداخلات ومداخلات العلاقات الثنائيه لا
تطلع شيء المذيع الاسرائيلي في قطر هو
دليل على ان الشعوب لم تطبع وهي ترفض
التطبيعه يعني احنا شاهدنا طبعا المياه
الاسرائيلي ومحاولاته المستهيده نعم
الشعوب العربيه
تفصل ما بين توقيع الاتفاقات وبين التطبيع
ان تسمح قطر لاكبر عدد من الفلسطينيين ان
يحضروا هذا المونديال وان يتم نشر عالم
فلسطين في كافه الملاعب مكتوب عليه الحريه
لفلسطين والسماء هذه ليست مساله مركزيه من
الحكومه القطريه
ارجوك هذه همم لك ما كنت تتابع تماما هناك
اعلام عديده لدول عديده ولكن هناك توجيه
معين من الناشطين الفلسطينيين ومؤيدينهم
على النت وعلى السوشيال ميديا لابراز عالم
فلسطين ومجرد حضور الوفود الاسرائيليه
والجماهير الاسرائيليه له قطر بصفره طائره
مباشره من تل ابيب او هي ليست تل ابيب على
فكره يوجد مطار اللد لا يوجد مطار في تل
ابيب هو مطار اللد هذه مدينه ااه القديس
الخضر جريس المحتله همم يعني هي شرق يافا
الى قرب من الرمله هذه والقائم هذا المطار
على اراضي فلسطينيه محتله ويسمونه هذه
بطوله دوليه هذه بطوله دوليه ومن المفترض
ان الدوله التي تنظم تسمح للجميع قطر
تحاسب على المثليين ومجتمع الميم وغير ذلك
بدوله من المفترض انها عضو في الامم
المتحده دوله احتلال واقتصاب ولكنها دوله
في نهايه
دوله دوله لديها علاقات لماذا يمكنك ان
تقول ان هذه الدوله لن تحضر ممكن ان تقاطع
ما المشكله في ان تقاطع او ان تقول نحن لا
نريد نحن شعب عربي اسلامي نتضامن مع
الاقصى والقيامه والقدس وفلسطين المحتله
اين هذا هذا
سيضاعف الهجوم الحملات الداميه على قطر
قطر تتعرض منذ فوزها بتنظيم المونديال في
2010 لهجوم داري بسبب صغر حجمها وعدم وجود
تاريخ رياضي وارتفاع درجه الحراره والخوف
من مساله حقوق مجتمع الميم واشياء من هذا
القبيل والعماله الاسيويه ووضع
الديمقراطيه وحقوق الانسان اذا ما اضفت
مساله الرفض وجود مشجعين اسرائيليين في
قطر انت بذلك تحكم على هذا المونديال
بالاعدام الاسرائيليون هجموا هذا
المونديال وطلبوا بمقاطعته وحواله
استغلاله من اجل التطبيع لكنهم فشله انا
انا
واضيف لقطر السماح للفلسطينيين بالخروج في
تظاهره
لمناهضه اسرائيل وتاييد التحكم الفلسطيني
طيب هي هي قطر يعني تعمل معروف علشان
ادخلت
الفلسطينيين جايين بتذاكر ببلاش يعني هل
كان من الممكن ان تقول لهم بتظاهره السماح
لهم السماح لهم بتظاهره يا دكتور خوري ل-
اا رفع اعلام فلسطين والتمديد باسرائيل
اعتقد ان دوله اخرى في اوروبا او حتى في
معقل الديمقراطيه في امريكا قد يمنعونهم
من هذا الامر على اعتبار ان اسرائيل اخبار
الناس
في الامم المتحده خلينا خلينا مكرم خلينا
مكرم اذن معنويه المعنويات الشعب الايراني
سترتفع في حاله الفوز ولكن في حاله
الهزيمه ستكون كيف هذه المعنويه
من الايرانيين او المؤيدين لايران بشكل او
باخر ولكن بالتاكيد ستمر هذه الازمه
النفسيه العابره هناك ما يسمى
بالجغرافيكيشن في مشاهده كره القدم اا اذا
ساعدتني من الترجمه من الفرنسيه الى
العربيه هذا النوع من السعاده لدى
الجماهير التي تحصل
مؤقتا
نعم نعم
سياسيا مؤقتا ولكن انا ايضا اتفق مع مع ما
قيل اعتقد من الاستاذه نجات انه يعني
بالصوره الكبرى لن تؤثر فعلا هذه المباراه
على العلاقات الدوليه جوهريا وانما على
الحشد الجماهيري والمعنويات وانه نحن
غلبناهم ونحن رصيناهم ونحن صفعناهم وكل
هذا هذه المفردات من الحشد الجماهير يعني
هي مساله في النهايه يجب ان تفحصها في
حسابات بلوك كل الشركات التي استثمرت في
هذا المونديال واولئك طبعا اللاعبين الذين
ربحوا ولكن انا مدين للاستاذ بشير بان
اقول وايضا للاستاذ نجاه اين ملك المغرب
في ملاعب الدوحه واين ايه ايه
النهائي ملك المغرب لم يحضر القمه العربيه
اصلا لم يحضر قمه جامعه الدول العربيه
نصف النهائي
باريس بس مش مشكله اه بحبها
يعني في عالمنا العربي في منطقتنا بما في
ذلك في ايران نحن نتمتع بروح رياضيه صراحه
طبعا انا عندما يكون هناك فوز تكون
المعنويات عاليه جدا
وتكون الدنيا مش سيعتنا على الطريقه
اللبنانيه بس ولكن عندما نخسر لا نتقبل
هذه الخساره بروح رياضيه في معظم الاحيان
يعني نحن اليوم مثلا هناك تحضيرات عديده
وتحضيرات امنيه
ما يتعلق بحضور هذا همم
يعني هذا الماتش الرياضي اليوم هو ماتش
اساسي خاصه انه هناك تحضيرات لسيارات
ستجول في الشوارع في حال فوز ايران على
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وكذلك ربما
تكون هناك هناك
ما بعد فوز الولايات المتحده نعم في ضحيه
وفي مناطق اخرى في عوكر وغيره للولايات
المتحده الامريكيه للفريق المؤيد لامريكا
وبالتالي يعني التنافس شديد جدا
والخساره يعني ستكون همم ربما ضرب اا قويه
بنسبه لايران في حال خسيرات وخرجت من
تاهلها خاصه انها كانت همم لديها ثلاث
نقاط يعني وهي تحتاج فقط للتعادل همم تكون
في الدوري 16
تفضل تفضل تفضل تفضل ضربه قويه لايران مش
ضربه قويه لايران
لا هي يعني الموضوع كله بصراحه همم ممكن
ان يعني نسافر سياسيه
نعم نعم ممكن ممكن ولكن طبعا يعني سيتم
غسيل كل ذلك اليوم الاخر وستاتي قضيه اخرى
وسيكون حشد همم جديد
لا يعني ممكن اي شيء يعني هو يعني بريزه
فرنسي
لم سنين الاخيره يا استاذ توفيق خلينا هلا
بس فرنسا مش مفقوده اليوم وانا سكران
هناك
مشكله
في هذه الاوقات او في هذه المناسبات يتم
حشد الشعور الوطني والقبلي وشعور الانتماء
عبر الرياضه وهذه مناسبه للجميع لكي يفرغ
عن شعورهم بصراحه لن يؤثر ذلك على
العلاقات الدوليه
مش عارف الدين زميله صحفيه وكاتبه سياسيه
شكرا من القاهره لبشير عبد الفتاح باحث في
الشان هل ايراني في مركز الاهرام للدراسات
السياسيه وليس استراتيجيه والتاكيد الذي
سيستضيفه في القاهره ضيفي من كبريتش مكرم
خوري استاذ العلاقات الدوليه والاعلام
السياسي على الاقل مواصله هذا النقاش
الشكر لفريق يا باشا جميع